hey guys I'm Ryan right Melissa be crazy
so today we're gonna check out the
trailer for a video game that of course
this morning I post four videos and I'm
thinking yes people are going to be
happy and satisfied because I'm catching
up on videos and then every comment
comes in saying fallout 4 how so I have
not made a lot of people happy because I
did not do the right video apparently oh
well then it takes time to put these
together guys alright fallout 4 not
gonna lie we don't really know much
about this game we know like basic facts
so don't expect us to be the biggest
experts on the video game okay doesn't
mean you have to hate us doesn't mean at
the cost [ __ ] just you know be nice
you're on the internet that's the best
way to get people to be nice to you ah
suggest things not to say Peggy 18 love
that guy
it's just like first one sign oh yeah
but the craw
the world poised on the brink of war all
around reporting a record folks wishes
to stand by variously ways intentions
the line drawn to forget about how much
I care for you
we seem to have lost contact with our
filling stations stand by we do have
coming in confronted reports of nuclear
detonations
oh my god
or sodas all right
we'll never change us
Oh
for dogs
let's go pal
oh it's Bethesda yes yes it is
love Bethesda honestly I didn't even
know that with them but that's yes let's
watch this again hmm
hey Peggy 88 I swore I'd watch it again
for that
no um first off I love this this fall
out thing from but yeah seen a lot more
fall out trailers and I have seen less
place up and watching and this is always
a delight because it's eerie
oh you know you got that kind of music
reminds you of it's a wimp
yeah of a light-hearted time you know
and then but it adds a certain kind of
melancholy when you see the symmetry I
love how they do I know I know I've
never seen a kill you not know love it
yeah I've never seen even a real-life
movie do that to seem to that's an
interesting way to establish past and
present no I just want to state though
uh that I'm actually implying a Last of
Us right now oh no I know
Thaksin being they have nothing to do
with each other but they're very similar
in style and I really like that yeah
yeah it's a really great style add a lot
and they have a lot of attention to
detail which is pretty not just on
graphics and John repulsion contract
award for station fantastic Emma had
this is a trailer alone this is a great
Erie trailer you know you can hear the
speech now leading up to the gutter
detonation right and then it's sad when
you like you're watching this dog run
and you see the people run it's like
this dog is reliving these memories
just want everything to go
yeah but at the same time as
post-apocalyptic world that's really
yeah it's kind of got a warm I'm about
me yeah you know I don't know if the
other ones do but I do like the play
having some bees probably not no I love
it
9
like think about it what if there was
some kind of you know nuclear or
happened today it happened nobody would
be prepared for that well I would I know
you I know how to here it'll brand
person let's go pal I love the idea of
our main hero being teamed up with a
buddy dog yeah because that's always a
delight in films so I like seeing that
in a video game actually um and then I
just hope they don't pull it I am Legend
that where's the killer I love that
movie you haven't seen I am Legend we're
gonna give you a spoiler right now
Will Smith beats his dog to death it's
really depressing punches it kicks it
stabs it and then shoots it in the head
and you watch the brains fly out it's
[ __ ] up and there was no reason he did
it there was no reason why he did it
oh he's just an abusive dog over and
then he calls himself legend hmm
ridiculous but no this game looks
fantastic and I don't mind watching
trailers to video game sequels even if I
haven't played the prior ones because
trailers have this amazing thing with
video games especially to make you go
damn I am actually getting what this
games about right right but I want more
answers so it makes you want to play the
other ones you know you should as as I
should yeah don't worry this weekend
working with your boyfriend on getting a
hatred gameplay up so games I'm sure
that's gonna happen just saying yeah
[ __ ] Dan if he doesn't let me do it
quote me on that show him this video
anyway well thanks guys for saying that
was out if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
could check out Alyssa P Crazy's Channel
and Alyssa has a beat gaming channel as
well so check that [ __ ] out and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter
we're normally I make a joke here about
getting product placement with a certain
amount of followers twenty five thousand
then but in
not a little bit what's the next work oh
yeah we'll do a shout out instead josh
lioness hey guys I have been watching
your video since last month and I gotta
say you guys rule no lies no ifs ands or
buts I've never really done something
like this but can I have a shout out
thanks guys
smiley face hashtag Ryan though Josh
lioness thank you so much man no lies no
ifs ands or buts or anal I love you
buddy
lioness that that is actually um a old
biblical word love that stood for demon
seed yeah we don't new every day lioness
was the son of Satan
well shoutouts gonna hand Josh cuz you
know we're cool though
we're cool I don't know if or okay no
we're cool got the [ __ ] camera